vous savez cette semaine lé annonce du
deuxième guerre mondiale de rémission
d'un patient atteint du vih a donné
vraiment beaucoup d'espoir aux personnes
touchées par cette maladie là malgré
l'importance de cette avancée les
médecins spécifie que c'est une
procédure d'exception qui ne pourra pas
être généralisé alors on revient ce
matin sur cette annonce
et sur ce qu'elle signifie vraiment pour
l'avenir de la lutte contre le sida à la
chronique science avec renault mais nos
gars a gagné d'abord revenons au bonjour
aujourd'hui on revient sur l'événement
expliqué nous un peu comment cette
personne non elle a intégré les deux
personnes
c'est le deuxième cas les deux personnes
dans le monde qui ont été qui sont
débarrassés du virus elles ont commencé
leur histoire avec une malchance assez
incroyable elle avait le vih est un
cancer du sein c'est un genre de cancer
qui peut être traitée par ce qu'on
appelle une greffe de moelle osseuse
donc on va on va te donner aux patients
la moelle de quelqu'un d'autre qui va
lui transférer un nouveau système
immunitaire et qui va éliminer le cancer
par la suite mais c'est pas un
traitement qui sans risque ça vient avec
un certain taux de mortalité qui peut
varier entre 15 et 40 % dépendamment des
circonstances et c'est toujours très
difficile de trouver un donneur qui est
compatible faut aussi dire que ce
traitement là et uniquement fait pour
trait se combattent le cancer n'est pas
sensé affecté le vih mais dans moins de
1% de la population mondiale on retrouve
une mutation qui vont rendre les gens
résistants à cette maladie donc ces gens
là n'ont pas un gène que le vih
utilisent normalement comme porte
d'entrée pour entrer à l'intérieur des
globules blancs et donc sally sall et
protège d'une certaine façon et si on
donne son fait une greffe de moelle à
des patients atteints du vih en leur
donnant la moelle de quelqu'un qui ose
cette résistance justement on illumine
son système immunitaire infectés et on
le remplace par un système immunitaire
résistant et il en faisait une pierre
deux coups se sont fait une pierre deux
coups donc on dirait cancer et on le
rend résistants voyage du même coup
comment fait un nom cela peut aider dans
la lutte au vih c'est sûr que c'est pas
une annonce qu on peut généraliser à
tout le monde ya trop de risques pour
que pour la faire à tout le monde ça
c'est pas garanti que ça va fonctionner
et trouver à la fois un donneur qui vont
être résistant au vih et qui va être
compatit avec la personne ça est presque
impossible dans la plupart des cas
mais l'idée que nourrir de cette
résistance génétique ça quand même
espérer beaucoup de chercheurs qui eux
travaillent dans les laboratoires pour
essayer dehors de donner aux patients
cette résistance sans les risques de la
greffe de moelle donc eu beaucoup
d'études ces dernières années où par
exemple les chercheurs prenait les
globules blancs des personnes
séropositives les modifiés en
laboratoire pour les rendre résistantes
et les redonner par la suite aux
patients atteints ses méthodes n'ont
jamais guéri de patience jusqu'à
maintenant mais dans certains cas les
chercheurs ont constaté que la quantité
de virus dans le corps de ces patients
le diminuer de façon importante donc il
ya des études qui continue à tuer ça
peut être une voie qui va être assez
intéressante à l'avenir par contre n'ont
pu imaginer qu'il ya quand même des
risques dans ce genre de procédure
c'est sûr qu'il faut toujours être très
prudent avec les modifications
génétiques la moindre erreur ça peut
entraîner des conséquences pires que le
problème initial
malheureusement eu quand même des
chercheurs qui ont tourné les points les
coins ronds on se rappellera en novembre
dernier avait ce chercheur chinois qui
avait annonc é a soulevé un tollé
international quand il a annoncé la
naissance de ses deux jumelles qui
l'avait modifié génétiquement quand elle
était encore des embryons mais c'était
sur son objet donné cette résistance au
vih dans ce que si c'était cela
l'objectif du chercheur lui voulait leur
donner cette même mutation là mais sa
méthode elle était non seulement
dangereuses mais en plus a pas
totalement fonctionné en plus faut dire
que c'est pas avec ce genre de mutation
locaux peut entièrement éliminé
l'épidémie de vih parce qu'il existe des
variantes du virus qui utilisent
d'autres mots les d'autres jeunes
d'autres portes d'entrée pour entrer
dans les globules blancs et où cette
mutation là ça les dérange pas trop donc
en ce qui concerne une solution
génétique au problème c'est ce que la
recherche avance cette annonce lors de
cette semaine est très importante mais
on ne peut pas s'attendre à un
traitement comme ça avant cinq à dix ans
au moins lorsqu'on parle de solutions
génétique justement on sait que le vih
chaque touche quand même des pays assez
pauvre à ce moment là lorsqu'on évoque
la possibilité de traitement
il ya des coûts associés à ça pour
toutes les thérapies génétiques gêné
qu'il faut des infrastructures il faut
des finances d'un financement qui est
pas disponible partout
donc c'est pour ça qu'à court terme le
moyen l'élément le plus important pour
combattre la pandémie
c'est vraiment d'améliorer la médication
qui est offerte
parce que vous rappeler qu'il ya 37
millions de personnes qui sont atteintes
du vih en ce moment là dessus seulement
59% des gens qui ont accès à un terrain
puis antirétroviral etc des médicaments
qui doivent être pris à tous les jours
ce qui est très difficile à vivre pour
les patients il ya des chercheurs
justement qui travaillent sur cet aspect
là du problème et c'est ça qui ont mené
à un autre deuxième annonce très
importante dans la recherche du vih
cette semaine
il ya des chercheurs qui ont annoncé qu'
il avait développé une injection qui
pouvait remplacer jusqu'à un mois de
thérapie antirétrovirale donc au lieu de
prendre des médicaments 365 jours par
année
en fait double injection par injection
donc cesser exigeant comme traitement ça
c'est beaucoup moins exigeant donc deux
nouvelles études qui sont parus sur ce
sujet reste à voir où tout ça va mener
c'est sûr que ça va pas guérir les
patients mais c'est quelque chose qui
pourrait grandement améliorer la qualité
de leur qualité de vie en attendant un
éventuel vaccin
et ça c'est quelque chose qui est
toujours très difficile à faire un
vaccin contre le vih parce que c'est un
virus qui était insaisissable beaucoup
de gens qui suivent les développements
de très près merci un cours non ça fait
plaisir